great right it's my salter here from
Toronto slightly rainy and cold Toronto
we're looking forward to coming up
spring to Canada so it's a pleasure for
me to be part of this webinar and taught
the opportunity to tell you a little bit
about what we've been working on in my
lab over the last number of years
related to nmda receptor function and
how that may be related specifically to
various disease processes and some
aspects of normal brain function so i'm
going to divide the talk into three
different parts first i'll tell you a
little bit about what we've been working
on in terms of them what molecular
events and regulate nmda receptor
function at least in the context in
which we work then i'll tell you a
little bit about s'more specifically
about regulation in a form of synaptic
plasticity known as long-term
potentiation and a little bit about what
we've been doing there and how we think
that may relate to some brain plasticity
deficits and then in the end a sort of
an emerging idea that we've been working
on together with John McDonald's law
here in Toronto about house our family
kinase is may regulate meta plasticity
three differentially regulating
different subtypes of nmda receptors so
I appreciate that some of you may not be
a biologist so just to make sure that
we're all along the same page what I'm
going to be talking about is the
fundamental unit of synaptic
transmission at least excitatory
synaptic transmission which is pervasive
in mammalian central nervous system the
brain and the spinal cord and what you
can see in this diagram is just a
cartoon that illustrates the way we
think about synaptic transmission at
these fast excitatory synapses so there
are presynaptic elements which release
glutamate in little vesicles and that
glutamate then is able to diffuse across
a very narrow synaptic cleft and
interact with two sets of strategically
localized types of receptors those are
the ampa receptors and the NMDA
receptors in the focus of what and what
I'm going to talk about is on nmda
receptors so what you can see here
in this part is related to what you
would observe the fuel recording
synaptic currents so this downward
deflection here is related to the
opening of ampa channels which come on
very rapidly after transmitters release
glutamate is released and then shut very
quickly nmda receptors on the other hand
kind of open a little bit more slowly
and stay open in a much more prolonged
fashion so you can see that a little bit
better down here you can see the nmda
receptor-mediated component of the
synaptic current out here in yellow and
I think it's probably readily apparent
to you that with these sort of timing
differences on the orders of a few
milliseconds to maybe a few hundreds of
milliseconds that the information
encoding through to end of the universe
that there's an anchor receptors is
quite different and I think it's
generally thought in the field that nmda
receptors and ampa receptors sort of
slightly different functions in million
central nervous system and perl
receptors are involved in fast synaptic
transmission at most synapses excitatory
synapses where's NMDA receptors are
involved in synaptic transmission at
some synopsis on an ongoing basis but
mostly they're involved in synaptic
plasticity or the modulation of synaptic
efficacy so this is just to give you an
idea of sort of what I think of it as an
electrophysiologist x-ray
crystallographic view of the NMDA
receptor the receptor is a multi-protein
complex which at the core is a
non-selective cation gem and what you
can see there is that nmda receptors are
permeable to small monovalent cations
like sodium and potassium and they're
well known to be permeable to to dive on
cations in particular calcium one of the
things that you may know about in immune
receptors is that they have a
permeability week permeability to
magnesium and the probably the way that
you know that is that the channels are
blocked by magnesium so when magnesium
comes into the channel and enters the
channel pore then front of the outside
it binds to a site where it essentially
get stuck so even though magnesium can
permeate the channel it essentially gets
stuck there and blocks the flow of
sodium and potassium and this is the
molecular basis for the so-called
voltage-dependent blockade of nmda
receptors so at hyperpolarizing membrane
potentials that's membrane potentials
with the Seldon cells in the central
nervous system normally find themselves
in the range of minus 60 to minus 70
millivolts resting membrane potential
the magnesium is blocking the channel
but when the cells depolarized during
high frequency trains and synaptic
currents then the magnesium is repelled
or is unblocked and that allows sodium
potassium and particular calcium to flow
through the channel so one thing that
you need to remember about these
channels if you don't already know is
that these channels are unique amongst
ligand-gated ion channels in that they
are co-receptors they buying both
glutamate hence the name of them being
members of the glutamate receptor family
but they also buy glycine and that's
shown over here so in fact the holo
receptor complex is made up of four
different agonist binding subunits two
for glycine and to predict what you can
also see here in something that's I
think most of us have come to appreciate
over the last decade or so is that the
channels are not simply the iron
permeation subunits but there are a
number of different types of
intracellular proteins and transmembrane
proteins which you don't see here but
intracellular proteins that are
associated with the functioning of your
channel and that's what my allows been
working on is how protein protein
interactions and proteins in the
intracellular demean of the channels how
do those regulate the function of nmda
receptors and so you can think about
this in two ways we think about for
example the basal flow of current
through the channels and what we
discovered a number of years ago and
I'll show you a little bit more as we go
along is that upon phosphorylation by
specifically by Sark family kinases or
Sark itself then there's phosphorylation
of sites on proteins within the channel
pore within the intracellular demeans of
the channel that allow the increased
open probability and I'll show you an
example of that as we go along which
increases the current flowed through the
the net of all the ion channels so one
thing that you can see up here is that
the channels are made of as I mentioned
two different types of subunits for all
together the glycine binding subunits
are the so-called glue in one subunit
and economy different splice variants
and then the glutamate binding subunits
are the circle glue in two subunits and
they coming for different flavors ABC
and D so in particular in the mammalian
central nervous system then the two
predominant subtypes of gluing two
receptors are they glue into a and
gluten to be and so you want to keep
that in mind that these are the
glutamate by any setting it's because
I'm going to come back and tell you more
about that at the end of the talk okay
so this is just an example from
recordings that you get in my lab almost
two decades ago now to give you a flavor
of the kinds of experiments we do to try
to determine whether the channels are
regulated for example by protein
phosphorylation or other signaling
processes so what you see up at the top
is a series of traces made from in this
case from pubic ample neurons that we're
going to record it in primary culture
and the downward deflection here comes
about by the application of very brief
application of in this case aspartate
linkages nmda as well aspartate to open
the channels that are on the Civic ample
neuron and the downward deflection then
represents the current that's generated
by opening of the channels and what you
can see is that over time 1 5 10 15 20
minutes the channel the current
generated by the same application of a
spark it gets bigger and bigger and the
reason for that is that during this
recording we allowed a protein tyrosine
kinase catalytic domain recognition here
to enter the channel through a patch
plant pipette so the concentration of
the Coyotes catalytic domain went up and
up over time and correspondingly that
the currents got bigger and bigger and
bigger as you can see here in another
experiment from another so also a hit
the kaplan right instead of putting a
protein tyrosine kinase catalytic domain
into the zone you put a protein tyrosine
phosphatase catalytic domain and in this
cell you see the current at the
beginning
this big and over time the current gets
smaller smaller and smaller indicating
that the phosphatase it entered the
channel so we can play these games back
and forth in this way adding Chinese
catalytic domains or activators of
kinase ha's in particular start family
kindnesses than the current enemy
occurrence got bigger and the
phosphatase for adding possibilities for
activators of possibilities made the
currents get smaller now for the rest of
the talk you need to know a little bit
about the tyrosine kinase arc and Sark
family kinase numbers so you can
understand the reagents and the
experimental approaches that we took in
the latter parts of the dark so this is
just a schematic cartoon that Lorraine
Kelly and I put together a few years ago
and it shows you the major domains of
stark family kinases so the one domain
that's very well known and well
conserved is the catalytic domain or the
so-called sh1 domain and then a couple
other doings that are very well known
are the sh2 domain which binds phosphor
tyrosine and the sh3 domain which lines
curling which sequences so within the
Sark family of chineses and there are
nine members of that family and the
catalytic domain the sh2 domain the sh3
domain and also the so-called sh4 demain
out here near the memory are all highly
conserved where the kinase is different
differ dramatically is in the primary
sequence of the unique Denis so the
cartoon shows you two different
confirmations of the channel or of the
kinase one in which the kinase is more
or less open on the right and then a
closed conformation of the kinase where
there's binding a tyrosine
phosphorylated residue here at the
c-terminus in this case based on the
chick numbering which is Tarzan 527
phosphorylation of that binds
intramolecularly to the Tsar SH to
Danang that puts the kinase in a closed
conformation there's also an interaction
between the sh3 domain and a cryptic sh3
binding site
in another part of the kindness and not
those two binding events really lock the
kinase in a catalytically inactive form
so the kinase can be moved back and
forth through a catalytic form and a non
catalytic form in large part by
phosphorylation or dephosphorylation of
this c-terminal kind of phosphorylation
site here so there's a specific kinase
that's involved in putting the phosphate
on there that's CSK and there's also a
specific phosphatase that's involved in
removing that phosphate which is a
receptor PTP alpha or PTP outfit so I'm
going to come back to those as we go
along one thing that one can do and
using a phosphopeptide magnetic I was
invented by Thome possums lot many years
ago now is that one can use this
sequence which I'm going to call it P
Yei peptide that this sark kinase
activating peptide which binds to the
sh2 domain here and prevents the binding
or reverses the binding of the
phosphotyrosine so this is a competitive
interaction so when the py e I peptide
binds and it binds with very high
affinity binds to the sh2 domain this
puts the kinase into the active
conformation so that's one region but
i'm going to show you that we've used
quite extensively in my lab and a number
of other lives to activates our family
finances on the other hand i mentioned a
couple of minutes ago that the stark
family kinase is diverged extensively in
the so-called unique denis and a peptide
that leave use that is unique for SAR
can differentiate sort from all of the
members of the SART family kinase is
this peptide which is a fragment of a
region and unique to me called SART
Phyllida fatigue so this in the context
of the NMDA receptors and this is a
functional inhibitor of the interaction
between Sark and its target put some of
its charter proteins in the NMDA
receptor complex so one thing to keep in
mind is that this peptide is not a
catalytic domain and come here so it's
not like AG Regents that you may know
about which inhibit the catalytic domain
some of those are PP 2 or SC 5658
the this is a peptide that inhibits
protein-protein interactions so those
two reagents I'll show you extensively
one is the PYD I peptide the activator
Sark family kinase activator and this
one which I'll call Sark 4250 is an
inhibitor in the context of the NMDA
receptor complex but not in necessarily
in other contexts so with those reagents
than you did experiments like this so
this is slightly different than the last
one I showed you here we're recording
spontaneously occurring miniature
excitatory postsynaptic currents that
come from the spontaneous release of
glutamate those coming sporadically and
this is again from cultured hippocampal
moons and what you can see here is the
ampa this by channel component of the
excitatory postsynaptic currents the
first part mediated by opening of ampa
channels and then this later part by
opening of nmda receptors and in this
cell then what we did was we infused
into the cell through the patch
electrode like this this p yei peptide
and what we found was that over time the
NMDA component of the current got bigger
and bigger this we proved that nmda
receptor-mediated because it was blocked
by the competitive blocker a my office
or local lyric acid whereas in this case
under the recording circum symptoms of
these the ampa component did not change
so you can see the NMDA receptor current
here getting bigger as compared with
over here so this was the kind of
evidence that we used in terms of
identifying start family kinase as their
sark itself being involved in regulating
NMDA receptor function so we can do this
kind of recording in a number of
different ways in this case we used a
small patch of membrane in which we
trapped and NMDA receptor and activated
with NMDA receptor plus glazing shown up
here and in this case we did we made the
patch recording in such a way that the
intracellular side of the patch was on
the outside or the interest other side
of the membrane was on the outside of
touch so that we could apply we
agents to the patch for example the py e
iPad touch shown here and we need many
different kinds of measurements here but
probably the simplest one is to
understand is that simply the open
probability of the channel and that's
plotted here over time and in this case
then we infused onto the intracellular
part this P yei peptide and what we
found was the open probability increased
progressively over time in another patch
what we did was instead of using the PYD
I peptide we use that Sark 4258
inhibitor peptide and what we found is
that channel function in this other chap
match went down so we could play this
game back and forth using either
activators or inhibitors of kinases and
phosphatases and the upshot of all that
is represented in this cartoon so the
way we envisage it is that nmda
receptors are controlled by a battle and
the battle is between Sark kinase itself
shown here and a phosphatase which I
haven't told you anything about yet
called striatal enriched phosphatase
discovered by pollen grow so many years
ago and Sark and step battle it out to
control the function of nmda channels
the important point is that the that the
phosphorylated channel activity is much
higher than the non phosphorylated
channel but as you can see here as I try
to represent down here the most d
phosphorylated state of the channel that
you can get we still find channel
activity so channel phosphorylation is
not required for opening of the channels
but rather for enhancing channel
function and so if you can think of
different situations if Sark is dominant
then channel activity goes up whereas
this step becomes dominant and channel
activity goes down as you can see
represented in the cartoon and also in
some example traces down here at the
bottom okay so this is the basic
paradigm that we've been working under
for a number of years now in terms of
trying to understand what this
regulation of channel function and da
channel function by sarkin stuff means
in the real
so you look at this in a number of
context and i'm going to show you couple
cartoons just related to one area that
we've worked at some level yoona a
mccain biologists interested in neuro
plasticity in pain and part of that
neural plasticity is importantly
regulated by nmda receptors and what we
discovered was you near in my lab a
number of years ago is that the
interaction of Sark with the NMDA
channel complex which we had determined
is mediated by this anchoring protein in
v2 but that interaction is critically
important for phosphorylation of nmda
channels and producing what we call pain
hypersensitivity exaggerated pain
responses that come about as a result of
a number of different kinds of injuries
in the periphery one of those might be
tissue damage by trauma inflammation or
injury to peripheral nerves so all of
these kinds of tissue damage then
converge on activating start in this
stark activation actually occurs in
neurons in what you would call the pain
pathway in the pain integrated network
region in the spinal cord dorsal on sir
there's a sensory processing area in the
spinal cord dorsal horn and through
inputs that come in from personal tissue
then there's activation of start by
pathways that we're still working out
but Sarge kinase gets activated and
causes phosphorylation of nmda receptors
and then that mediates exaggerated and
pathological pain responses so we've
used what we what I call here the unique
domain peptide or the side 4258 peptide
in a version that we made membrane
permeable so we could give that either
systemically your locally at the spinal
level so this unique domain peptide then
uncouples Sark as I told you about a
couple of times now by its interaction
unique domain and a binding site here on
the anchoring protein MV 2 so this
unique domain peptide then uncouples the
kinase from the receptor and then allow
step which you don't see in this picture
step 2 d phosphorylate the channel and
then reversed pain hypersensitive so
there's a whole series of experiments we
did back and forth using
electrophysiology behavior in
biochemistry to sort of validate
this model so that's one context in
which you think this regulation of the
mune da receptor function by the battle
between sarkin stuff is extremely
important in this case Sark wins the
battle and causes pain hypersensitive
another area where we've done work on
Sark regulation bhindi receptors in the
phenomenon of long-term potentiation so
many of you will be familiar with this
idea this phenomenology which is has
been most extensively studied at this
synapse here between Schaffer
collaterals of c3 knowns synapsing on to
see a one neurons in the hippocampus so
that these synapses there's an nmda it's
well known that there's an nmda
receptor-mediated form of long-term
potentiation and there's a number of
different kinds of stimuli which when
delivered for example here can enhance
synaptic efficacy which means that the
strength of synaptic connections which
are plotted along here so this is the
basal synaptic efficacy and at this
point a conditioning stimulus for
example hundred Hertz tetanus or beta
burst stimulation is delivered very
briefly for a period of a few seconds
arrest and that produces a long lasting
facilitation or potentiation of the amp
occurrence oh this is potentiation of
ampa mediated synaptic transmission and
what's been known is that nmda receptors
are absolutely critical for this so that
this Schaffer collateral siguen sit-ups
is pretty typical for the NMDA receptor
dependent form of long-term potentiation
so when we're talking about long-term
potentiation for the rest of the talk
this is what we're talking about nmda
receptor dependent synaptic plasticity
that Schaefer collateral see they
weren't synopsis so a number of years
ago in that many years ago actually
giving Lulu when he was a postdoc in my
lab and together with John rotor then
produced a body out of and some of which
is shown here to indicate that Sark
upregulation of in da receptors is
critically important for
the induction of long-term potentiation
so I'll just take you through the slide
briefly server on the left side here
what you see is experiments where you
mang was recording using patch clamp
electrodes from ca1 neurons and in some
neurons like this one here he infused
into the neuron of the Sark inhibitor
peptide in other neurons he used a
scrambled sequence of the sarkan peptide
which we knew did not inhibit Sark in
the context of the NMDA receptor in
particular this scrambled peptide does
not inhibit the interaction between SARC
and the anchoring protein me too so in
neurons where he used this control
peptide there was potentiation after in
this case this was a hundred Hertz
stimulation gear so hundred Hertz too
tannic stimulation produced this
potentiation and was unaffected by the
scrambled Sark map died but this
potentiation was completely negative I
the Sark inhibitor pendant which you can
see here so this is one example cell
here is their field recordings just to
show that we actually deliver into the
stimuli and here and in oops down here
and in the group data is shown here on
the other hand we used a number of
different reagents we used another one
showing here which is a function
blocking the anti Sark antibody that had
been developed by John Gregg Islam which
we used over here it the reason that we
use the static 4258 inhibitor peptide
was that this was in fact the antigenic
peptide that John bergey's law had used
to generate this SAR computer antibody
so again with the Sark inhibitor
antibody there was no long-term
potentiation and cells will affect where
you need to defuse that antibody game
but in kinsella infuse to control non
specific igg then there was the LTP just
model again this is the grip data and
this is just the field recordings from
the same recording field potential
students and recordings just to show you
that we actually delivered the Titanic
stimulation and in cells in which there
was no peptide or antibody infused that
there was still long-term potentiation
so this was part of the evidence that
led us to this
which we've refined a little bit over
the years as our lab and other labs have
sort of flesh type many of the details
so on the Left which you can see is the
idea of basil synaptic transmission so
in the hippocampus in at least in brain
slices then md currents are
biochemically down regulated by in
essence step winning the battle that i
told you about reform so step is down
regulating the function of nmda channels
and Sark is in fact as far as you can
tell virtually not on at all so there's
two aspects to the down-regulation of
mmva channels the way we see it one is
the blockade by magnesium which
everybody knows about and the other
thing that you may not know but until
you listen to this talk which is that
there's down-regulation of nmda currents
by this biochemical mechanism here what
we envisage happening after or just
around the time of titanic stimulation
or theta burst stimulation these
continued conditioning stimuli that give
rise to long-term potentiation is that
there's a number of events that occur
one of them is the well-known relief of
magnesium blockade so there's no made me
no no museum here and then there's also
biochemical activation of Sark through a
number of different pathways that
converge and start to activate sorry and
there's also down-regulation step and
another interesting phenomenon we think
is going on which was discovered by
Shannon Union my love a number of years
ago is that the Sark phosphorylated
version of the NBA channel complex is
sensitive to intracellular study so
during a titanic and theta burst
stimulation these high frequency trains
a stimuli then we can see that sodium
would go up is the channel are there
dendritic spines get loaded with sodium
so sodium would increase and that in
essence the NMDA channel gets a triple
boost one by relief of magnesium
blockade to buy the starcross violation
itself in the third by this potentiation
right interests our diversity so though
the way we see it then is that those
three processes conspire to dramatically
increase
MDA receptor function and dramatically
drive calcium to the cell and then
there's a whole series of well known and
well characterized biochemical steps
that need to either an increase in the
number or the function of an amp
occurrence so here's the idea that you
recruiting amp occurrence to the cell
surface and the channels to the cell
surface and the idea that the function
of ampa channels may increase as well so
this is how we see the biochemical and
electrophysiological steps that go on to
produce long-term potentiation in the
hippocampus at that well at least this
enemy receptor-dependent form at Shaffer
collateral seeing one's denounces so
we've been investing that for many years
and a long time ago now he started to
work with lee mays lab because Lynn was
interested in New regulan signaling
through EGF receptor and quynh ances and
approached us with the discovery he made
that one of these EGF receptor family
kinase is in particular early before he
had found to be localized within the
NMDA receptor complex now we were
interested this was many years ago now
and we were interested in trying to find
upstream regulators of Sark family
countenances you have more kinase as or
phosphatases and so we started to work
with names lab on understanding first
determining whether early kinase you'll
be for a particular could regulate
synaptic transmission or annum being
receptor function and to make a very
long story very short what we found was
that in hippocampal slices again when we
recorded field epsps right now not a
whole saga accordingly recorded the
pocket of the population response we
used this up tied ligand regulan one
beta to activate her before a well-known
activator and when we applied in a
regular long-dated just before we gave
in this case again too tannic
stimulation what we found was that we
could virtually entirely abrogate the
induction of long-term potentiation
showing down here in slices that were
treated with purvi for with a regular
one to activate early fall so you can
see that here in the population data as
compared with control data so we've been
investigating that for a long period of
time so that was the basic phenomenology
at the same time Linds lab had found as
I mentioned a couple minutes ago that
early for as a member of the NMDA
receptor complex mates in the NMDA
receptor complex by virtue of its
c-terminal binding to one of the pdz
domains of the major scaffold which many
of you will know the major scalpel in
the NMDA receptor complex psd-95 so lens
lab had determined that and as I said
this is what got us interested in the
possibility that urban your before might
regulate and da receptor function and
synaptic plasticity so just a couple
points about this there is a bit of
controversy in the field about where it
or before is localized so what we see is
that early for immunofluorescence
decorates the dendritic spines in the
ca1 pyramidal cells this is a seeing one
pyramidal cell here you can see the
dendrites here and this red
immunofluorescent these little dots are
all along the dendrites of c1 pyramidal
cells along with richard weinberg and
lin then Richard looked in this case
this was cortical neurons but again at
spiny synapses and one can see using
electron microscopy that urban her
before immunogold labeling is there
within dendritic spines for example here
and here in another example here of
dendritic spine labeling of early for in
the cortex this so these large gold
particles are or before the small gold
particles which I hope you can see for
example here are actually psd-95 in the
growing room so I think there's
reasonable evidence than that it's
finding synopsis in the hippocampus and
the cortex there's Ruby for co-localized
with the other components of this post
optic receptor Cromwell's at the time
that we were doing these experiments
then we were interested from the
perspective of synaptic plasticity a
receptor function the genetics community
had through a variety of studies
implicated the two proteins we were
working on at the time regulan one the
agonist and Ruby for the receptor as
being major determinants of risk for
schizophrenia and so this is just going
to summarize a cartoon from the maze
review from the number of years ago
describing some of the allelic variants
that are associated in supreme so there
is now quite a bit of evidence
implicating narrating one in her before
as major risk genes for schizophrenia
since that so that got us quite
interested in the possibility that the
work we've been doing on synaptic
plasticity and functioning might be
relevant to schizophrenia since then
there have been a number of different
studies that have further implicated the
three work in humans but this Kirby for
an irregular ones signaling may
contribute to schizophrenia so for
example chumby Hans loudly together with
steve arnold described the number of
years ago now in this neutrik innocent
paper using extra PSD extracts from
schizophrenic brains and also put normal
control brains that there was nmda
receptor hypofunction in specifically in
the context of new regular one Ruby
force signal coincidentally along the
way and a number of enzymes that are
involved in regulating nmda receptor
functions on which I told you about
before for example PTP alpha remember
this is the phosphatase that
dephosphorylates that c-terminal by 27
tyrosine when it's phosphorylated by cos
K so PTP alpha has been implicated in
schizophrenia and also this gene PTP and
fog which is the gene that encodes for
step allelic variation also implicated
as a risk for schizophrenia so a number
of lines of you could think of a
circumstance
evidence but at least evidence that was
consistent with the idea that nmda
receptor regulation by a number of
signaling pathways that converge on step
and Sark may be involved in state
Supreme so sorry buoyed by that then we
started to look a little bit further
into this and this is just to remind you
again about this fundamental observation
that we made which is that a regular one
has this very powerful effect of being
able to first have absolutely no effect
on basil synoptic transitions is a very
important point no effect on basil
synaptic transmission but this dramatic
ability to absolutely wipe out the
induction of long-term potentiation so
we've looked at that in a number of
different ways the first part was to
actually get evidence that the ER before
signaling was involved in the
disaffected Nura Galen and you did that
with grand pitcher in my lab using a
couple of different approaches one was
using cardiac rescued early for knockout
mice burger before deletion use
embryonic lethal there's cardiovascular
rescue then the animals are fine and
what's a gram found which is summarized
in this histogram is that in early for
no animals represented here there's a
couple different phenomena first that in
those animals the degree of potentiation
the bezel long-term potentiation is
actually greater than in control animals
but importantly the effect of no regulan
one beta to decrease long-term
potentiation right or tape at least of
the doses needs to hear to produce this
massive decrease in long-term
potentiation oh was completely abrogated
in mice lacking or before okay so Graham
could do that either in 34 miles or
using one of a very number of different
kinds Kirby kinase inhibitors now of
course these inhibitors like PD with
this pd compound are not necessarily
selective amongst the different family
members and so this is why we combine
the inhibitor with the data from the ER
before knows to give us this idea that
first there's ongoing regulation by her
before signaling right you can see that
again
lockerbie signaling here we get this
enhancement of Basil's of which and I
think of this basil ltp and also that
the ability of nagaland one beta to
inhibit long-term potentiation is
dependent upon her the kinase so this is
just some of the population data again
for that and so armed with that then we
started to think about a couple of
things in all those experiments that I
just showed you in the bath applied no
regulon 1 beta 2 the entire slice we've
started it just before a few minutes
before the conditioned stimulus which
might be tetanus or when what the rest
of what I'm going to show you is we've
always used a diversity image so when we
do that and apply no regularly 1 beta
just before the conditioning stimulus
and we can prevent the production of
long-term potentiation and here here but
if we apply in a regular one beta after
the potentiation has been developed for
about 30 minutes or so when we see no
change here no change in the amplitude
of the synaptic currents or epsps in our
interpretation of that is that a regulan
one beta is an early for signaling are
inhibiting the induction but not the
maintenance of long-term potentiation
athletes analysis so it's during that
induction time you recall that's why we
think nmda receptors are getting
activated by that triad of chemical and
electrophysiological things that i
mentioned before so again one important
thing is that no regular one has
absolutely no effect on nmda receptor
function basil immigrants are completely
resistant either to New regulan 1 beta
or to the pde compound so it's not that
when we used a regular lund data we're
simply downregulating in MDA crimes
we're not doing that at all it's
straight for collateral sequence
announces there must be something else
going on to prevent the induction of
long-term potentiation so then to just
bring you back to one of the other
reagents that we use remember I told you
about this sorry phosphopeptide so I
family kinase phosphopeptide ocular
so in the experiments granted here in
hippocampal slices recording from CA 1
yards infused in the py e I activating
peptide and found that the amplitude
event the NMDA component of synaptic
currents got bigger and bigger and
bigger this is not here but in cells
where he had pretreated with no regular
on beta these ones here then there was
no increase in the regular one beta
pretreatment was able to prevent the
enhancement that we knew otherwise was
mediated by circuit silk with the
circuit and an activator accountant so
essentially cutting off the ability of
sarcoma kind uses to increase in a view
receptor function and you can see that
in the number of different ways this is
just again the formal proof that the
this ability to suppress the enhancement
I know this is an odd several double
negatives so the ability of new
regulator and one beta to suppress the
enhancement by d ye peptide that's
prevented in animals that lack or before
in is also prevented by treatment with
the again a different Irby kinase
inhibitor so again the idea is that this
effect on a regular undated phenomenas
phenomenology of suppressing stock
enhancement of nmda receptor currents is
mediated by early for receptors so one
aspect of this in terms of schizophrenia
is that if your schizophrenia Liga's
then the place you're probably
interesting to you most is not
necessarily the hippocampus that may
well be the prefrontal cortex so we
asked Evelyn lamb at the University of
Toronto been to do recordings where she
would first determine whether an EA
currents in prefrontal cortex neurons
are controlled by side friendly kind
uses the way you think they are in ca1
shaper minus e1 synopsis and that you
can see here so infusing this Pyo Yong
peptide increased and at the NMDA
component of synaptic currents at
Shaffer collateral synapses and that new
regulan one just like in ca1 synapses
reglan when beta was completely able to
prevent that
enhancement of nmda Curren by circling
by the py e I peptide so this
phenomenology of preventing this
penetration is not limited to see a one
and should the campus but we also see
evidence for that in prefrontal cortex
as well so one question you might ask is
remember I've been telling you this P
whining I peptide then can activate
start family kinase is not just circ so
whether this phenomenology that I'm
telling you about about my regular mom
beta in world's Sark or another of the
circuit any Chinese members so grand I
gave me my lab did experiments using
either wild-type mice up here or SAR
kill mice so Mike mice lacking Sark that
had been generated by Phil Soriano's
logging in years ago he found a couple
things first he found that there was a
slight but significant decrease in the
amplitude of long-term potentiation in
the Sark null mice which you can see
here comparing way up here to the
wild-type mice so that was one sort of
predictable aspect the other aspect is
that in wild-type mice then you see this
decrease in long-term potentiation
produced by pretreatment with raymond
data but in the Sark null mice even
though there was some long-term
potentiation a residual LTP this LTP was
completely resistant to the treatment
with New England one beta and also with
inhibitors of pervy kinase as well so
there was no enhancement of that so the
idea being that Sark then is necessary
for this no regular one data signal not
only is it necessary but the effect
occurs very early in the in the
conditioning train so this is just an
example of average recordings of the
very first of a diverse trainings so we
used data burst which is four pulses at
a hundred Hertz separated by 100
milliseconds what you see then is this
is the reason this is the response to a
single action potential are a singer
stimulus and single input
and then these progressive responses
going all the way up to here are the
responses to this for setup for verse so
this is the depolarizing angular now
we're recording not in voltage clamp
here but in current clamp so you see
this is a membrane potential
depolarization produced in response to
either a single or the burst and a cut
there's a couple things one is that no
regulan one beta has absolutely no
effect on the response to the signal so
although you can't see it there's a
black trace generate underneath the
green trace here but what you can see I
think quite dramatically and clearly is
that the neury going 1 beta effect is on
the depolarization that occurs as a
result of the verse so you can see this
dramatic difference here between control
slices untreated with regular long data
and spices that have been treated with
regular 1 beta 2 so I think that the
ability of an irregular long data or
before signaling can occur very early in
the process of long-term potentiation
induction maybe just with a couple or
three or four inputs so this is the
model that Graham and I came up with a
number of years ago to sort of put all
this together you know Carl now that
I've told you a few times this idea
about tonic regulation and
down-regulation of envy points in basal
synaptic transmission but this
biochemical pathway of eternity isn't
showing any detail here other than to
mention again this idea that early for
signaling is causing a basil or ongoing
support suppression of long-term
potentiation induction enhancing the
regulan early for signaling then can
essentially shut up or dramatically
suppress synaptic plasticity in this
case long-term potentiation conversely
and what may be going on in some
excitability situations for example like
chronic pain or perhaps epilepsy is that
there's enhanced synaptic plasticity so
moving no regulating one or before
signaling either up or down then can
have this effect either suppressed when
your regular one signal goes up or than
one or before see when it goes up or to
inhibit or her further
at synaptic plasticity layer before
arreglen once again goes down so this
idea of plasticity apostasy I'm going to
talk in the last few minutes about a
little bit more about met apostasy this
idea of signaling in this way so this is
our model the reason that we so the idea
in terms of schizophrenia then as I told
you a couple times now there's no effect
of new england won her before singling
I'm Baeza basil Anthony Davidson optic
transmission or on basil singling
through nmda receptors with single
inputs so the idea that's out there is
that schizophrenia maybe a hypo function
of nmda receptor sigma our take on this
is that that it may not be hypofunction
of nmda receptors per se but its loss of
Sark mediated enhancement so hypo
plasticity or hypo function of nmda
receptors in the context where they're
up regulated by synaptic transmission so
in the last couple minutes and I'm just
going to tell you very briefly and
goofily quite click with this idea that
we've been working on together with john
mcdonalds on it which sort of builds
from the idea that we got three there
before signaling about meta plasticity
so the idea that plasticity can is
actually switchable or the gain of the
process it can be changed so this is
just to remind you about this idea that
we can now butts are currently kinase is
at the center of regulation of MND
currents and many different signaling
pathways have been implicated in
regulating the function of circling like
I'm uses in his contacts some of those
are g-protein-coupled receptors which
are shown down here and John McDonald's
office done a lot of work on this and
I'm going to make a go through these
last few slides quite quickly so the
idea with these is that there's a
subunit specificity so I ask you to
remember way back to one of the first
slides that I should be a while ago to
remember that andy subunits the
glutamate binding subunit is coming four
different flavors these are the glue in
twos so gluten to a to be or two cotd
the predominant ones in the
zena's our glue in 2a and 2b and what
John's lab had found that activating
start and has a preferential effect of
enhancing the function of glue into a
containing receptors this can be done
even with recombinant sonic or by
stimulating g-protein coupled receptor
pathways such as the pact 1 receptor
that preferentially activates arc so
conversely and differentially there's
enhancement of nmda currents but
preferentially have the glue into be
subtype when the stark family kinase
member finn is activated so thin
enhances of them you going to be
mediated currents and receptor function
whereas sonic seems to preferentially
enhance glen to a containing an immune
receptors so that's important for this
idea about frequency dependence of
synaptic plasticity so some of you are
probably familiar with this kind of a
graph where high frequencies like a
hundred Hertz or undershirts and TBS
synapses particularly c1 Schaffer
collateral synapses potentiate here
whereas at lower frequencies of steam
women then the predominant change in
with those jingle I patterns and
frequencies is to depress so the idea is
that or has been proposed that that
which that this plasticity frequency
response curve is shiftable and
shiftable on the basis of the relative
contribution of glue in 2a are gluing to
be subunits so given that this idea that
such friendly kanye's art can enhance i
glue into a containing subunits then
what John's lab found was that this
frequency response was shifted to the
left so stimuli that in particular with
frequencies that would produce
suppression or long-term depression
caused in fact excitation whereas
activating the field pathway shifted
this frequency response the other way so
that in particular here you can see that
stimuli that produced
Russian this frequency then had no
effect or he'll frequencies that had no
effect actually cause potentiation I'll
write the questions right away so then
John's lab was able to take advantage of
work done mostly by tedashii Yamamoto
slab that had implicated a number of
different phosphorylation sites in this
sea term and I blew into a into D
receptors as being important in the
effects of sarkar fin on those receptors
and what John's lab found was that the
Sark potentiation of glue in to a4a glue
into immediate occurrence was completely
blocked in mutant mice knockin mice
where this tyrosine here had been
replaced by a phenylalanine preventing
phosphorylation and conversely this site
england to be where at 1427 when this
star seems you place by friend allowing
then the effect of activating fin is
completely blocked this is in terms of
the responses to exogenous nmda
responses to synoptic ly released
glutamate in terms of the synaptic
released epsps the NVA component of
epsps and so the idea is that over that
this frequency response curve can be
shifted so there's meta plasticine
that's not only based upon the receptor
subunit whether it's too late Oh to be
but also upon these regulatory events by
SAR kremmling kindnesses so that for fin
in terms of its ability to enhance going
to be promotes long-term depression
where it has Sark by its ability to
phosphorylate glue into a promotes
long-term potentiation so this is the
basic model that we've been using
because we think that a number of
disease entities may be related to
alterations and meta plasticity so we're
starting to investigate not now so I'm
going to end there and just remind you
that we
have this idea that such family kinase
is in particular Sark and fin are
important regulators of nmda receptor
function that these kinase is themselves
can be regulated by a number of
different signaling pathways and in
particularly the ones that i've talked
about hour before signaling and also
signaling through g protein-coupled
receptors ok and now I think let me just
end by just showing a list of the many
people have been involved from my lab
here in Toronto and also from the lives
of many of our collaborators in Toronto
and also in the United States so I'm
going to switch over and you choose my
glasses now to read some of the
questions okay so okay so I think
somebody was asking me about I'm going
to just go back to this slide because I
think that will be a little bit easier
so one of the questions is does Sark and
modulate ampa receptors directly so
Ricky owners odd does have some evidence
that sarcolemma kinase made sacral
encounters is made modulating ampa
receptor function in our hands and I
think in a number of people's hands in
John McDonald open a number of other
people what you see is that nmda
receptors are preferentially activated
and we don't find any evidence for
direct effects of StarClan makan uses on
the ampa receptors someone was asking
what's our so hopefully we've been able
to explain what Sarkis is so Sark was
the first unka gene that was identified
as the kinase that movie to the effect
of the roast sarcoma virus so this is
more Sark but its name I think that's
maybe what some news asking and somebody
else is asking are the presynaptic
mechanisms relevant to nmda receptor
needed ltb so this has been a big bone
of contention
I think in the field I think the
preponderance of evidence has really
coalesced on that this verb which you
may think of as early ltb is primarily
mediated by post synoptic mechanisms as
I described through changes in first
nmda receptor function and then
ultimately in either the function or a
number of ampa receptors at the cell
surface so either an increasing number
or an increase in their function of ampa
receptors as the primary mechanism there
maybe then with for example with late
long-term potentiation are also
rearrangements of the synapse and some
pre synaptic connections but this for a
form of LTP that we're talking about i
think is primarily mediated by
postsynaptic mechanisms ok looking to
see ok I think that is the last question
so I am going to put up for those of you
that are eligible for CME credits this
is the link where you can get your CME
credits and I thank all of you for
listening